après avoir passé sa journée entre
l'école et l'hôpital
anaïs rentrer chez elle mais sa journée
n'est pas terminée
soucieux du développement de leur fille
les parents sont allés chercher plus
loin que ce que pouvait proposer la
médecine française des méthodes dites
alternatives souvent non reconnu par la
france
c'est beaucoup d'investissement parce
que du coup il faut rééduquer donc tout
aussi bien la marche mais la parole que
les bras et du coup au quotidien il faut
la stimuler la solliciter même si elle
est très très volontaire et qu'elle a
très très envie de progresser
ces thérapies c'est à l'étranger que les
parents sont allés les chercher
méthode et santis biofeedback ou encore
la méthode medek à laquelle anaïs
s'exerce tous les soirs quand redescend
doucement on plie les jambes puis les
gens mais les mains devant je te tiens
bien demain les exercices qui expose
l'enfant à la gravité dans l'objectif
d'obtenir une réponse active elle fait
des exercices en fait par exemple en
montrent longtemps sur sur des boîtes en
bois où on la met en situation de
déséquilibre pour qu'elles puissent à
appréhender et retrouver son équilibre
et ça lui permet comme ça de garder une
posture bien plus droite une méthode
très physique mais chronophage pour les
parents anaïs réalise tous les soirs des
séances d'une demi-heure environ mais
qui selon eux portent leurs fruits
on a vu qu'elle enquête faisait
énormément de progrès notamment sur la
marche parce que là au mois de décembre
elle a pu faire ses premiers pas tout
seul et on essaie de la stimuler au
quotidien pour pour qu'elle puisse
continuer à avancer
une partie de ces thérapies se fait à
l'étranger notamment en espagne des
déplacements très coûteux qui ont
nécessité la création d'une association
pour aider au financement de ses soins
mais aussi pour le matériel trop peu
remboursés par les assurances sociales
anaïs une petite fille extrêmement
soutenue par ses parents qui mettent
toutes les chances de son côté pour
améliorer son état physique avec
l'espoir de la voix peut-être un jour
marcher et parler comme tout le monde